another very emotional ceremony
happening this evening this one at the
healing garden downtown and that's where
we find our victoria sahab with a
preview of that
[Music]
good morning heather yep this garden
will be filled with friends and families
of those we lost on that tragic night
remembering and honoring each one at the
healing garden
the healing garden started soon after
the october first shooting 58 trees were
planted here to honor and remember the
innocent lives that were taken that
night countless hours and volunteers
made sure the city of las vegas had a
place to mourn and reflect since then 58
trees have blossomed mayor carolyn
goodman says this healing garden shows
that life in las vegas continues even
after a horrible tragedy but the city
will never forget the events of october
1st 2017. later this evening the mayor
and the city communications director
will read the names of the 58 lives lost
along with where they were from and
their age at the time
we're all about
really trying to build a better life for
everyone and i think this touches us
each so deeply
that it's a time of
gratitude
that we're those of us who are still
here have that joy of loving sharing and
helping each other and yet to tell the
families of every one of these people
that we remember them
mayor goodman says this garden has
become the heart of this community a
bell toll will be
taking place along with a candlelight
vigil the ceremony is set to start at 10
05 p.m that's when the first shots were
fired reporting live from the healing
garden victoria saha live local now